[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Bettina Schausten
guten Abend in der Berliner
Bundespressekonferenz geht es eher
selten um Fußballer heute gab es Anlass
die Bundesregierung ließ mitteilen man
hoffe darauf dass sich Nationalspieler
Joshua Kimmich doch noch impfen lasse
Kimmich Vorbild gerade für junge Leute
und bisher ganz vorn dabei im Kampf
gegen Corona hatte am Wochenende
überraschend bestätigt dass er selbst
noch gar nicht geimpft sei fehlende
Langzeitstudien gab er als Grund an das
schlug ein denn in Zeiten wieder
steigender Inzidenzen erscheinen
Vorbilder mit Skepsis ziemlich
kontraproduktiv
so sehen die Zahlen aus wir schauen Sie
uns mal an das Robert-Koch-Institut
meldet heute
6.573 neue corona-infektionen das sind
2517 mehr als vor einer Woche 17
Menschen starben im Zusammenhang mit dem
Virus die Inzidenz liegt nun bei 110,1
den vollständigen Impfschutz haben
66,2% der Bevölkerung selbst wenn der
Wert etwas höher liegen dürfte ist es zu
wenig um eine neuerliche Überbelastung
der Krankenhäuser auszuschließen das
aber über die Impfstoffe bei aller
Aufklärung nach wie vor Mythen im Umlauf
sind zeigt die aktuelle Debatte Oliver
Heuchert fast sie zusammen
Josua Kimmich ist das was man einen
Fußballstar nennt 26 Jahre alt meist
defensives Mittelfeld beim FC Bayern
vorgestern sorgt er mit einem Interview
bei den Kollegen von Sky für Empörung zu
Gerüchten dass er noch nicht gegen kobit
19 geimpft sei sagte
[Applaus]
warum
ja weil ich einmal für mich persönlich
noch ein paar Bedenken habe gerade was
fehlende Langzeitstudien angeht es geht
einfach darum dass ich noch ja ein paar
Farbe denken habe und deswegen ist es
auch sehr gut möglich dass ich mich in
Zukunft impfen lasse in Deutschland gilt
keine Impfpflicht auch nicht für
Fußballstars
also natürlich darf er das das ist eine
private Entscheidung die Impfung ist
aber schon ein bisschen schade weil er
einfach doch jemand ist zu dem sehr
viele Menschen aufschauen viele
Millionen hören ihm zu es einfach ein
Vorbild und der ist einer
Falschinformation aufgesessen das ist
dann natürlich einfach ein bisschen blöd
Joshua Kimmich beruft sich auf noch
fehlende Langzeitstudien es geht um
bisher nicht der Kante Langzeitfolgen
das so etwas bei Impfungen passiert
schließen Wissenschaftler aus allein
schon deswegen weil der jeweilige
Impfstoff den Körper nach kurzer Zeit
schon wieder verlassen hat ich denke man
muss immer ruhig und sachlich aufklären
über die Impfung die Impfung ist
mittlerweile milliardenfach verimpft
worden ich selber bei einem meine dritte
Impfung bekommen wir wissen dass
Nebenwirkungen sich in den ersten Wochen
zeigen es gibt akut Nebenwirkungen aber
der Benefit ist deutlich höher als das
Risiko die Wissenschaftler sagen
Impfschäden die erst lange nach der
Impfung auftreten gibt es nicht es kann
nur sein dass Schäden gleich nach der
Impfung erst nach längerer Zeit als im
Folge erkannt werden
auch nach Meinung der Bundesregierung
sind die Fragen die Josua Kimmich
aufwirft längst geklärt es gibt auf
diese Fragen klare und überzeugende
Antworten von nationalen und
internationalen Experten und so dass ich
eigentlich nur sagen kann ich hoffe dass
Joshua Kimmich diese Informationen alle
noch mal auf sich wirken lässt und sich
dann auch vielleicht für die Impfung
entscheiden kann die Lage auf den
deutschen Intensivstationen ist derzeit
nicht angespannt knapp 1.700
kovid-patienten werden versorgt trotzdem
fürchten sie hier dass sich das bald
ändert wenn die Zahl der Infektionen
weiter schnell zunimmt
ja da lohnen noch ein paar Nachfragen
Carsten watzel ist Professor für
Immunologie an der TU Dortmund und auch
im Vorstand der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für Immunologie wir erreichen ihn heute
Abend in seinem Institut in Dortmund
schön guten Abend Professor
ja erste Frage kurze Frage muss man
Angst haben vor Langzeitfolgen der
corona-impfung
nein weil da reden wir über sehr sehr
seltene Nebenwirkungen und wir kennen
mittlerweile die Nebenwirkungen die bei
den Impfungen Auftreten und die sind so
selten dass man sich eigentlich keine
Sorgen machen muss das Risiko durch die
Infektion ist bei allen Altersgruppen
eigentlich viel höher als das Risiko
durch die Impfung also eine Abwägung
aber nun gab es ja eben Nebenwirkungen
von corona-impfungen etwa diese
sinusvenenthrombosen
herzmuskelentzündungen allergische
Reaktionen da ist sind so sorgen doch
nicht unbegründet oder
es ist natürlich so dass die Impfung ja
nicht nebenwirkungsfrei ist natürlich
hat sie Nebenwirkungen sie ist auch bei
einigen Menschen hat sie auch schwere
Nebenwirkungen aber das sind halt
Einzelfälle also bei den Sinuswellen
Thrombosen reden wir bei ein bis zwei
Fällen von 100.000 geimpften bei den
allergischen Reaktionen ist es ähnlich
bei diesen herzmuskelentzündungen ist es
ein Fall von ungefähr 16.000 geimpften
Kindern und das zeigt einfach dass das
seltene Ereignisse sind und da ist die
Infektion leider sehr schwerwiegender
aber jetzt ist ja Josua Kimmich
vielleicht nicht der einzige der darüber
nachdenkt ob so neue Impfstoffe
vielleicht Spätfolgen also spätere
Folgen auslöst die auch die Wissenschaft
noch gar nicht kennt oder kennen kann
deshalb noch mal konkret die Nachfrage
kann der Piks heute in einem oder zwei
Jahren Folgen für die Gesundheit haben
lässt sich das wirklich ausschließen
ja das lässt sich ausschließen also das
was Leute hier unter Langzeitfolgen
verstehen ist dass ich mich heute impfen
lasse mir ist die nächsten paar Wochen
und Monate eigentlich gut geht aber
nächstes Jahr habe ich irgendeine
Erkrankung die auf die Impfung
zurückzuführen ist und so funktionieren
die Impfungen nicht die Impfung lösen
eine Immunreaktion aus und während
dieser Immunreaktion kann es zu
Nebenwirkungen kommen das ist in der
Vergangenheit auch schon passiert aber
die sind dann auch innerhalb von ein
paar Wochen wieder abgeschlossen also
das mit einem Jahr was passiert das ist
halt ausgeschlossen das heißt dann
würden sie wie gerade die Vorsätze des
Ethikrates Frau Büchs in unserem Beitrag
sagen das sind im Grunde
Falschaussagen den die aufgesessen sind
die jetzt sagen wir warten noch auf
Langzeitstudien
das ist vollkommen richtig ist es
natürlich kontra intuitiv wenn man sagt
dich die Impfstoffe sind sehr schnell
entwickelt worden und dann gibt es sowas
wie Langzeitfolgen das scheint sich ja
zu beißen und deshalb muss man das
erklären und ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt
dankbar dass der Kimmich das aufgebracht
hat weil das ist offensichtlich eine
Frage die nicht nur er sondern viele
Leute umtreibt und dann kann man das
hier noch mal klarstellen kann man das
klarstellen und zu diesem was treibt
einen um zu diesen Dingen die so weiter
berichtet werden gehören bei jungen
Leuten gerade auch immer so Vermutungen
dass der Mana Impfstoff dass er in
irgendeiner Weise die Zeugungsfähigkeit
die Empfängnis stören könnte sind das
aus ihrer Sicht also auch dann
irrationale Ängste
das sind leider fehl-informationen die
häufiger mal wieder bei verschiedenen
Impfstoffen gestreut werden das war bei
früheren Impfungen wurde das auch schon
behauptet hat sich nie bewahrheitet und
auch jetzt was bei der corona-impfung
behauptet wird dass das in die
Fruchtbarkeit oder bei der
Schwangerschaft zum Beispiel negative
Folgen haben soll das hat sich alles
nicht bewahrheitet ganz im Gegenteil wir
wissen leider dass die Infektion ein
Problem für die Schwangeren darstellt
und auch was mit der Fruchtbarkeit
machen kann und sie sagen es ist im
Grunde ja auch so dass Nebenwirkungen
wenn dann werden sie längst aufgetreten
im Grunde auch für junge Leute nicht
eine Gefahr sind das also die Vorzüge
der Impfung ja deutlich überwiegend was
würden Sie denn sagen wie groß ist die
Gefahr für ungeimpfte junge Leute jetzt
wo schon über 60 70 Prozent geimpft sind
also was man aktuell sieht ist dass ich
sehr stark die nicht geimpften anstecken
und im Prinzip hat man nur die
Möglichkeit oder die Wahlmöglichkeit
sich seine Immunität entweder durch die
Impfung abzuholen oder halt durch die
Infektion einen dritten Weg gibt es
leider nicht und das muss jeder für sich
selber entscheiden natürlich ist die
Infektion für ein 30-jährigen
wahrscheinlich mit einem sehr geringen
Risiko behaftet 0,1% oder sowas einen
schweren Verlauf zu haben aber das
Risiko durch die Impfung liegt halt bei
0,001 % und von daher wäre das sinnvolle
natürlich sich impfen zu lassen dann
haben wir das klargestellt ich danke
sehr Professor Warze in Dortmund danke
so deutschland wartet auf eine neue
Regierung Mitte der Woche werden die
ampelarbeitsgruppen mit der konkreten
Arbeit beginnen der Nikolaus soll uns
dann die Koalition und einen neuen
Kanzler Olaf Scholz bringen soweit der
Plan gewählt haben wir vor nunmehr vier
Wochen aber nicht den Kanzler sondern
die Abgeordneten des Deutschen
Bundestages ihre Mehrheit braucht wer
ins Kanzleramt einziehen will und es
sind noch mal mehr geworden zusätzliche
Stühle wurden montiert und gestritten
wird immer noch über die Sitzordnung wer
sitzt wo morgen nun konstituiert sich
der 20 Deutsche Bundestag und Welt sein
neues Präsidium aus Berlin Andreas
Kühnast
man bekommt einen Abgeordneten Ausweis
eine Jahreskarte der Deutschen Bahn und
den Hinweis seinen Impfnachweis nicht zu
vergessen Maximilian motorhorst ist 25
Jurastudent und ab morgen Mitglied des
Deutschen Bundestags 1 von 736 dann
bekommt man das darf man auch nicht
leugnen ich finde das wird gerne
vergessen eine ganze Menge Privilegien
also nicht ganze Stange Geld und
Fahrdienst den man mitnutzen darf das
finde ich wird immer gern so ein
bisschen verschwiegen ist aber extrem
wichtig und ist auch für mich ein
Riesensprung man muss vielleicht neu
sein um sich noch wundern zu können wie
langsam die Tür ist und wie riesig das
Haus der 20 Deutsche Bundestag wird der
größte sein aller Zeiten noch einmal 27
Abgeordneten Ausweise mehr Mahlzeit es
wird noch enger im Plenarsaal und noch
wichtiger neben wem man sitzt und neben
wem nicht
es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche Stories
was man so hört was ich jetzt oft
mitbekommen habe ist ist es sehr
unangenehm neben der AFD zu sitzen von
der AFD will die FDP schon lange weg
aber erst jetzt hätte sie die Macht und
die Ampel Mehrheit dazu
cdu/csu müssen fürchten dass sie zum
Tauschen gezwungen werden wenn man uns
da jetzt irgendwo über stimmen wird dann
halten wir das also für sehr sehr
bedauerlich wir halten es für falsch ich
glaube man sollte mit neu gewonnener
macht dann auch entsprechend angemessen
umgehen es ist der Tag des Machtwechsels
im Bundestag der letzte an dem Wolfgang
Schäuble 79 noch ein Amt hat der erste
an dem Bärbel Bars 53 noch keins hat
aber schon Fragen danach abwimmeln muss
bitte nicht okay ab morgen dann ab
morgen heute ist ja noch alles offen die
SPD-Fraktion stellt Bärbel Baas heute
als Bundestagspräsidentin auf die
CDU-Fraktion die sächsische Abgeordnete
Yvonne marquas als
Vizepräsidentin und die AFD den
Thüringer Michael Kaufmann als ihren
aber seine Chancen stehen schlecht ich
persönlich werde ihn nicht wählen und
ich habe auch Respekt vor jeder anderen
persönlichen Entscheidung denn am Ende
des Tages steht es ja geschrieben dass
jeder Fraktion ein Vizepräsidenten
bekommt aber es steht auch geschrieben
dass wir Abgeordneten freies Wahlrecht
haben moin moin na hast du schon
abgeholt
ah ja mache ich auch da für die erste
Sitzung morgen muss jeder Abgeordnete
geimpft genesen oder getestet sein wer
keinen Nachweis bringt darf nicht
reingelassen aber auch nicht
ausgeschlossen werden deshalb werden
sich die Gegner der 3g-regel auf der
Tribüne wiederfinden
und warum lassen sie sich nicht testen
weil ich
jede Maßnahme die diese Corona
Zwangsmaßnahmen unterstützen ablehne am
Nachmittag wählt die Linkspartei ihre
bisherige fraktionsdoppelspitze auch zu
ihrer neuen alte Bekannte werden die
neue Legislatur prägen und neue
Gesichter morgen 30 Tage nach der Wahl
wird die erste Sitzung eröffnet
und dann verabschiedet sich auch Angela
Merkel und wird auf der tribüneplatz
nehmen sie erhält morgen ihre
Entlassungsurkunde auf europäischer
Ebene gab es für die deutsche Kanzlerin
schon viele warme Worte auch Frankreichs
Präsident macron dankte seiner Freundin
Angela für ihre so wörtlich
ausgefochtenen kämpfe für Europa auf dem
deutsch-französischen Tandem war macron
in 16 Jahren schon der vierte Mitradler
für Angela Merkel nach Chirac sarkozi
und ulland nun kommt von deutscher Seite
ein neuer dazu der nach Ansicht macrons
sicherlich auf dem hinteren sattelplatz
nehmen sollte allerdings in einem halben
Jahr muss sich macron erstmals selbst
dem Votum erstmal selbst dem Votum der
Wählerinnen und Wähler stellen dann wird
in Frankreich gewählt seine größte
Chance besteht momentan in der Schwäche
seiner Gegner berichtet aus Paris Thomas
Walde
der Weg zum Elysee führt über die
Zapfsäule ein halbes Jahr vor der Wahl
ist sie für viele Franzosen die
wichtigste Wegmarke wir können es uns
nicht leisten ein Euro 75 für einen
Liter Diesel zu bezahlen das ist der
Norm wir können nicht mal mehr mit dem
Auto fahren weil das ein Luxus geworden
ist das ist schade
das Rezept des Präsidenten lautet Geld
100 Euro gibt es für jeden
Geringverdiener im Land wir wollen die
Kaufkraft bewahren von Menschen die
überall Preiserhöhungen sehen
durch das Land wie heute bei einem
Roboterhersteller in santedieren und
verspricht Hilfen und Investitionen und
Investitionen und Hilfen wir geben 800
Millionen Euro in ihren
Unternehmenssektor
das Innenministerium bekommt eine
budget-erhöhung von 1,5 Milliarden Euro
mehr als 500 Millionen Euro für
erneuerbare Energien noch hat macron
nicht offiziell erklärt dass er wieder
antritt aber seine Auftritte wirken
schon wie Wahlkampf ihm kommt zugute
dass seine Gegner nur schwer ins Spiel
kommen am Wochenende in Lille Auftritt
der sozialistischen
Präsidentschaftskandidatin anidalgo ihr
größtes Problem bevor sie macron
angreifen kann muss sie erst Grüne und
Linke Präsidentschaftskandidaten
ausstechen und deren Anhänger hinter
sich versammeln
unser Kampf für den Umweltschutz darf
uns nicht spalten denn es sind die
Ärmsten die am meisten leiden unter dem
Klimawandel
höhere Steuern für Reiche will idal
goden auch sie hat teure Pläne
ich denke dass man in einer Amtszeit das
Gehalt derjenigen verdoppeln kann die
Schüler unterrichten
Kaufkraft und Gehälter das Thema in
Frankreich nur nicht für ihn Erik semour
hetzt mit ausländerfeindlichen
resortiments er assoziiert Zuwanderer
mit Vergewaltigern und Mördern die EU
ist ihm ein Gräuel Deutschland auch
Deutschland lacht heimlich wenn die
Franzosen vom französisch-deutschen
Tandem sprechen Berlin arbeitet nur mit
französischer Diplomatie zusammen um
unser Wissen abzugreifen im Bereich der
Verteidigungsindustrie
Samur bietet Polemik und sonst wenig auf
die Frage wie er die praktischen
Probleme der Franzosen lösen will wie
ihre Kaufkraft sagt er
in einer Präsidentschaftskampagne geht
es darum große Linien zu definieren und
nicht darum ins Detail zu gehen
Semur hat seine Kandidatur bislang nicht
erklärt macht aber schon der
rechtsextremen Marine Le Pen Konkurrenz
die bürgerliche Rechte verkämpft sich
derweil in parteiinternen Vorwahlen und
die Linke ist gespalten ein halbes Jahr
vor der Wahl ist macrons größte Stärke
dass seine Gegner ihm ihre Schwäche auf
dem Tablett servieren
und die Nachrichten beginnen mit einer
politischen Kehrtwende Gundula Gause
der türkische Präsident erdogan ist von
der angedrohten Ausweisung zehn
westlicher Botschafter abgerückt er
reagiert damit auf Erklärungen mehrere
Betroffener Botschaften in Ankara sich
nicht in innere Angelegenheiten der
Türkei einzumischen Erdogan werdet das
als Einlenken 10 westliche Botschafter
darunter der deutsche hatten die
Freilassung des türkischen
kulturförderers kavalar gefordert so wie
der Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte 2019 seit vier Jahren
sitzt Kavala ohne Urteil im Gefängnis
vorgeworfen wird ihm die Unterstützung
regierungskritische Proteste
die Konzentration klimaschädlicher
Treibhausgase in der Atmosphäre hat nach
UN-Angaben einen neuen Höchstwert
erreicht die Welt wetterorganisation WMO
warnt die Erderwärmung schreite weiter
voran mit verheerenden Folgen wie
Hochwassern Dürren und Hungersnöten
trotz der Pandemie sei der aktuelle
Anstieg stärker als im Schnitt des
vergangenen Jahrzehnts um das 1,5 Grad
Ziel zu erreichen müssten die Staaten
schärfere Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
vereinbaren schon bei der
Weltklimakonferenz ab Sonntag im
schottischen Glasgow
die Europäische Arzneimittelbehörde EMA
prüft die Zulassung eines neuen
Medikaments gegen kovid 19 das Mittel
molnupiravire wird von den
us-pharmaunternehmen Mörk sharp and Dome
und Ridgeback hergestellt ersten
Testergebnissen zufolge soll die Pille
die Wirkung des Virus im Körper
abschwächen stationäre Behandlungen und
auch Todesfälle könnten verhindert
werden in der EU gibt es mit remdesivir
erst ein offiziell zugelassenes
corona-medikament
CDU-Chef Armin Laschet hat wie
angekündigt sein Amt als
Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen niedergelegt zum
Nachfolger soll am Mittwoch im
Düsseldorfer Landtag NRW
Verkehrsminister Hendrik wüst gewählt
werden der 46-Jährige ist seit Samstag
auch neuer Landesparteichef der CDU
Laschet hatte vor der Bundestagswahl
seinen Wechsel nach Berlin angekündigt
da er nun Mitglied des Deutschen
Bundestages ist
vor dem Oberlandesgericht München ist
eine is-rückkehrerin wegen Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit zu zehn Jahren
Haft verurteilt worden die heute
30-Jährige soll vor sechs Jahren im Irak
tatenlos zugesehen haben wie ihr
damaliger Ehemann ein fünfjähriges
jesidisches Mädchen im hoffestband und
verdursten ließ Jennifer W habe nichts
dagegen unternommen obwohl dies möglich
und zumutbar gewesen sei zu dem
Gerichtsurteil spricht wulff-schmiese
später im heute journal Update mit der
Deutsch jesidischen Journalistin und
Menschenrechtlerin düsentecal
es war ein Putsch mit Ansage der sich
heute am frühen Morgen im Sudan
ereignete das Militär übernahm die Macht
setze die Übergangsregierung ab und
verhängte einen Ausnahmezustand damit
sind die Hoffnungen auf eine
Demokratisierung des Landes nach der
Revolution von 2019 zunächst mal
zerstört der Sudan am Horn von Afrika
gelegen und drittgrößtes Land auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent kommt nicht zur
Ruhe massive wirtschaftliche Probleme
eine unsichere Ernährungslage seit
wochenproteste auf den Straßen die
Generäle haben das ausgenutzt nachdem
ein erster Putsch im September noch
abgewendet worden war auch wenn die
jetzigen Machthaber Versprechen das Land
auf dem Weg zur Demokratie halten zu
wollen glaubwürdig ist das nicht Anna
wasberg berichtet
das Volk ist stärker rufen Sie und
protestieren damit gegen eine
Militärregierung zehntausende
Demonstranten sind auf sudansstraßen
stecken Reifen in Brand die
Sicherheitskräfte reagieren scharf
mehrere Tote und rund 80 verletzte
meldet dass du dannisische ärztekomitee
die Stimmung ist aufgeheizt
was das Militär gerade tut ist ein
Verrat an allen Zivilpersonen an allen
Fronten es ist unsere Pflicht etwas zu
bewegen die Straßen zu blockieren und zu
verhindern dass ich irgendeine
Militärregierung formiert
[Musik]
fast 30 Jahre lang regierte hier Oma al
Bashir 2019 wurde er aus dem Amt
getrieben nach Massenprotesten und
Militärputsch seitdem Übergangsregierung
aus Militär und Zivilisten ohne viel
Fortschritt im Land jetzt hat das
Militär die Macht übernommen den
Ausnahmezustand ausgerufen und verkündet
die Übergangsregierung sei aufgelöst
ab heute bis zu den Parlamentswahlen
2023 werden wir uns kümmern um die
Renten der Menschen Sicherheit bieten
und ein geeignetes und friedliches
Umfeld schaffen für politische Parteien
damit die Wahlen wie geplant stattfinden
können
die Menschen hier fordern seit Monaten
politische und wirtschaftliche Reformen
weil sich die Lebensbedingungen in dem
verarmten Land während der
Übergangsregierung nicht verbessert
haben Experten befürchten dass sich die
Lage im Sudan nach dem Putsch erstmal
weiter zuspitzen wird und noch mehr
Menschen als bisher in die Nachbarländer
fliehen
weil sie alle Angst haben sie haben
Angst vor dem wirtschaftlichen Teil der
Erhöhung der Preise und um ihre
Sicherheit und sie haben Angst vor
militärischen Auseinandersetzungen
das Internet wurde abgeschaltet der
Flughafen geschlossen
Ministerpräsident Abdullah hamduk soll
von Angehörigen des Militärs verschleppt
worden sein an einen unbekannten Ort und
aus dem Ausland hagelt es Kritik
der deutsche un-sonderbeauftragte für
Sudan volker Perthes twittert ich bin
zutiefst besorgt über die Berichte über
einen anhaltenden Putsch und die
Versuche dem politischen Übergang im
Sudan zu untergraben ich fordere die
Sicherheitskräfte auf diejenigen die
unrechtmäßig inhaftiert oder unter
Hausarrest gestellt wurden und
verzüglich freizulassen im Sudan ist
eskaliert was schon seit Monaten
gebrodelt hat in einem krisengebeutelten
Land mit sehr ungewisser Zukunft
ja mit Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft
geht es jetzt hier weiter Gundula die
Finanzmärkte sind auch in diese neue
Woche mit sorgen gestartet der
corona-krise sind lieferkrisen gefolgt
viele Materialien sind knapp die
Energiepreise dazu hoch die Folge der
ifo Geschäftsklimaindex ist zum vierten
Mal in Folge gefallen Frank die Stimmung
in den Unternehmen also eher trübe und
kein Licht am Ende des Tunnels für
dieses Jahr wohl nicht mehr im Gegenteil
die Aufbruchstimmung die im Sommer noch
in den vorstandetagen vorherrschte ist
verflogen fast quer durch alle Branchen
zeitgleich mit dem Geschäftsklimaindex
ruderte heute auch die Bundesbank in
ihrem aktuellen Monatsbericht zurück ein
Plus von 3,7 Prozent wie ursprünglich
für dieses Jahr prognostiziert sein
mittlerweile unrealistisch zur gleichen
Erkenntnis kamen bereits die führenden
deutschen
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute sie
senkten jüngst ihre Vorhersage von
ebenfalls 3,7 auf nur noch 2,4 Prozent
aus der Corona ist inzwischen eine
abheizkrise geworden die ihren Höhepunkt
noch nicht erreicht hat Logistiker
sprechen davon dass wir sehenden Auges
in einen Versorgungsengpass laufen denn
Deutschland hat einen strukturelles
Problem 60 bis 80.000 Lkw-Fahrer vielen
bereits heute und jährlich werden es
mehr dieses just in time wie es ja in
der Wirtschaft lange Zeit praktiziert
worden ist muss immer mehr aufgeweicht
werden es müssen mehr gelagert werden
weil nicht nur die Rohstoffe nicht
nachkommen sondern dann auch die
fertigen Produkte nicht dementsprechend
ausgeliefert werden können aufgrund von
dem lkw-fahrermangel wobei man eines
festhalten muss der Fahrermangel
verschärft die Lieferengpässe zusätzlich
Hauptursache aber ist er nicht die
Hauptprobleme liegen weiterhin darin
dass es immer noch an wichtigen
Rohstoffen und Vorprodukten
mangeltmann vielen Dank
Millionen Jugendliche haben online beim
langenscheid-verlag abgestimmt und das
Wort Grinch zum Jugendwort des Jahres
gekürt übersetzt etwa peinlich oder zum
Fremdschämen das könnte es ab jetzt auch
werden wenn auch Erwachsene es
vielleicht in ihren Sprachgebrauch
übernehmen so ganz neu ist das Wort
Grinch nicht im letzten Jahr landete es
auf Platz zwei hinter lost verloren in
der Pandemie
eine Meldung vom Sport neuer Trainer des
VfL Wolfsburg wird übergangsweise
Michael fronzek der 57-Jährige war zuvor
Assistent von Cheftrainer Mark van
Bommel von dem sich der VfL gestern nach
acht sieglosen Partien getrennt hatte
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat in Rom
mit Papst franziskus über die
Glaubwürdigkeitskrise der katholischen
Kirche gesprochen diese müsse sich den
missbrauchskandalen Stellen Betroffene
Opfer und Politik erwarteten Transparenz
und ein beispielhaftes Vorgehen der
katholischen Kirche sagte Steinmeier bei
der Privataudienz ging es auch um
wachsende humanitäre Krisen etwa in
Madagaskar und Afghanistan sowie den
bevorstehenden Klimagipfel im Glasgow
Papst franziskus äußerte die Sorge dass
die Politik den Erwartungen an die
Konferenz nicht gerecht werde
und nun ein echter Krimi den uns unsere
Kollegin Daniela Sonntag aus Thüringen
erzählt aber einer mit Happy End es geht
um den spektakulärsten Kunstraub in der
DDR Ende 1979 in Gotha es geht um fünf
alte Meister die verschollen waren
betrauert wurden und dann wieder
auftauchten 40 Jahre später nun sind sie
zurückgekehrt an ihren Platz in Gotha
die alten Meister und können bestaunt
werden ihre abenteuerliche Geschichte
aber ist noch immer nicht ganz
aufgeklärt
sie glänzen sie leuchten und sie sind
wieder dort wo sie hingehören die fünf
Meisterwerke aus der Gotha Kunstsammlung
jetzt Stars einer Ausstellung über
Verlust und Rückkehr also ich neun Jahre
alt war sind die Bilder verschwunden
heute ist mein jüngster Sohn neun Jahre
alt und ich kann ihm die Bilder wieder
zeigen dass es einmalig eigentlich sage
ich mal Grenz schon fast an Wunder dass
sie wirklich hier wieder gelandet sind
die Geschichte der fünf filmreif 1979
Gotha nicht irgendein Kunstraub der
größte in der DDR Polizei und
stasi-rekonstruieren zwar wie die Bilder
im Wert von 5 Millionen D-Mark aus
Schloss Friedenstein abgeseilt wurden
doch weiter nichts rund 40 Jahre bleiben
die Werke unter anderem von Franz Hals
und Hans Holbein verschollen bis sich
2018 bei gotas Oberbürgermeister der
Rechtsanwalt einer Familie meldet im
Gepäck fünf Umschläge
aufgemacht habe und sah darin
Farbfotografien der Gotha Gemälde die
eigentlich vorher noch keiner gesehen
hat war mir klar was ich in den Händen
halte und mir war gleich bewusst wenn du
jetzt nicht zugreifst Knut dann wird das
nie was es kommt heraus die Bilder
hingen offenbar über Jahre im Wohnzimmer
der westdeutschen Familie vermittelt
wohl einst von Rudi B mutmaßlicher Täter
Lokführer und DDR ausgereister nach
einem Jahr Geheimverhandlungen der große
Kuh in Berlin davor ein Transporter in
den Hof und auf einmal wurden in
Noppenfolie eingewickelte fünf Pakete
gebracht und eigentlich hätte ich dann
nur heulen können in diesem Moment weil
der war so emotional
Rudi B ein Einzeltäter oder nicht vieles
an der Geschichte immer noch ein Rätsel
das erzählt auch die Ausstellungen Gotha
fakt ist nur der Umgang mit den Bildern
war laienhaft Farbspritzer Rahmen aus
dem Baumarkt von hinten waren diese
Bilder dann mit Nägeln in diesen Rahmen
befestigt und auch das tut natürlich
eine Holztafel die 500 Jahre alt ist
nicht sonderlich gut über Monate wurden
sie nun durchleuchtet restauriert mit
alten Rahmen neu in Szene gesetzt und
Überraschung das Bildnis eines alten
Mannes könnte womöglich gar ein
Rembrandt sein die Forschung noch am
Anfang der Kunstraum hat ja nicht nur
die Öffentlichkeit bestohlen sondern
eben auch die Wissenschaft das war über
40 Jahre lang nicht möglich sich mit
diesen Kunstwerken zu beschäftigen die
fünf geraubten sind zurück aber gut 70%
der ehemaligen herzoglichen Sammlung
bleibt als Lehrstelle an den Wänden
verschollen verkauft oder verschleppt
die Geschichten von Verlust und Rückkehr
noch bis August nächstes Jahr in Gotha
was für eine Geschichte so viel von uns
um Nummer 30 meldet sich wolfsschmiese
mit unserem heute journal Update und
jetzt natürlich das montagskino tschüss
bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
ein schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja eine ruhige
Hochdruckwetterlage hat sich ausgebildet
und zwar liegt es an dieser
Hochdruckbrücke die von Osteuropa über
Mitteleuropa bis auf den Atlantik
rausreicht dabei hat sie ein Tief im
Griff und das bewegt sich kaum vom Fleck
und immer wenn Tiefs hängen bleiben und
über längere Zeit stationär sind bringen
sie Extremwetter und das hier bringt 300
bis 400 Liter auf den Quadratmeter
anregen bis Freitag in Süditalien ja bei
uns gibt es eine Kaltfront die
allmählich ostwärts zieht und die bringt
in der Nacht schon ganze im Westen viele
Wolken und Regen nach Norden gibt es
einzelne Gewitter im Osten viele Wolken
Richtung Bayern da klartis auf und es
bildet sich Nebel bei null Grad kann es
dann auch zu Reifglätte kommen sonst
nach Nordwesten in milder weit 10 Grad
morgen im Tagesverlauf verlagert sich
Kaltfront langsam ostwärts von den
westdeutschen Mittelgebirgen über die
norddeutsche Tiefebene bis nach Norden
hin viele Wolken an der Ostsee auch
Blitze und Donner im Osten Deutschlands
da kommt die Sonne hervor so ähnlich
wird es dann auch ganz im Süden sein
wenn sich der Nebel auflöst die
Temperaturen erreichen höchste Werte von
16 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands 10 bis
15 Grad in den anderen Regionen und in
den nächsten Tagen bleibt es im Prinzip
sonnig sofern sich der Nebel auflöst
ganz im Norden am Mittwoch viele Wolken
bei 9 bis 17 Grad ähnliche Temperaturen
am Donnerstag Freitag ein wenig mildern
allerdings dann häufig mit Nebel im
Osten viel Sonnenschein ein schöner
Abend